we was on a plane we took a picture in
front of the window
we watched around the
uk it was
very green and very
beautiful
country
much different than afghanistan
after that
we was discussed because
many things and over
hate
from afghanistan
after the chaos of the evacuations from
kabul in august 2021 thousands of afghan
refugees on resettlement schemes headed
to the uk bound for safety but still
processing what had happened
my team reported and witnessed the
scenes of desperation at the airport
people crushed to death trying to get to
sanctuary others swarming over the
runways as planes took off some clinging
to the fuselage of transporter planes
we watched as thousands stood knee-deep
in a canal filled with sewage hoping to
be seen heard and allowed onto a flight
many of those feared for their lives as
western forces withdrew from the country
and the taliban seized control
with nothing more than hand luggage
those who did make it on board flights
still had no idea what lay ahead or even
where they might end up i'm stuart
ramsey and in this second episode of the
sky news podcast out of afghanistan
we'll hear what happened next to the
people who arrived here in britain
and ask how many that are entitled to
come may still be in afghanistan
afsal used to work with the british
military in afghanistan and is
resettling in britain with his family
this has been a traumatic journey for
them his wife was pregnant and they had
three children under the age of eight
when they battled through kabul airport
at one point his daughter was abducted
in the chaos
they've now landed safely in the
midlands but with few possessions the
british people
they
told us with warm welcome or they gave
us some food or some clothes and on
birmingham
airport
but they arrived while kovid was still
rampant
so put in a quarantine hotel they had no
idea what the rules were or how to go
outside i know understand about we have
a break and we can go out after 11 days
some of my friends he called me
i [ __ ] every day we go out and you
know come out you can ask the security
guys and they will organize for you and
for the other
nine days i went out for 20 minutes
every day with my children and just we
walk around there there was a small
garden
life here is completely different
especially the food there was a prepared
some
burger
meat
price
different foods
but
my wife and my children they know eat
that i i was work with the
uk guys and i understand about their
their uk food and it was very good for
me but my family
during that 19 days
just they eat their chips and
some biscuits nothing wrong
after quarantine there was a new hotel
in an unknown place we sat on the taxi
and we don't understand where we go
just i
checked the google map to where we go
on the taxi
brought us direct today to the bristol
city
i never hear about bristol
before when i came to here
just i
heard about some city in about the uk
because i like football
and afghanistan i watched
the premier league um also the champions
league i was known about the liverpool
manchester united
arsenal chelsea six nil
but i never heard about the bristol city
yeah and right now i saw i i know the
bristol city have a
football team and i i went on time
the home office has put afghan refugees
in bridging hotels while they find them
more permanent accommodation which could
be in any of 300 local authorities in
the country in this episode we're
joining absal and others in bristol
where some of the refugees have agreed
to share their experience
[Music]
two large hotels here have become home
to hundreds of refugees mostly families
in one two whole floors have been set
aside for them
the afghans are now effectively living
in a community doors are kept open and
children play in the corridors
having escaped afghanistan shibano has
now been reunited with her husband yusuf
in britain
family showed us where they're staying
it's about 20 families here all from
afghanistan yeah we have to use our card
so you go to the door
so it's a bit miss stop the room
you have a little fridge here
this is our coffee stop we make our tea
here
and this is our kettle yeah we are
leaving three people here my daughter
nine years old and me and my husband
and for my daughter we have a sofa bed
and for us we have a
double bed and also a table and
tv
yeah yeah one chair extra
it's my daughter keyboard
we made a lot of friends here
and we sit in one room like we call each
other we just
speak and talking and also we sometimes
we play
yeah so the problem in they have they
receive a letter or email something i
see and i translate for them and telling
them what's the
yeah to do next and also
sometime we play lodo
because
we don't have
to do anything that much with me i play
another instrument it's called rhubarb
i brought this from afghanistan and this
is my only friend
it's all wooden
and it's about
45 years old
it's have three main strengths
which is
these three main strengths and then it's
um
just other like other music instrument
but you have to have played with both
hand as a guitar and guitar also we have
fingers on the
bands
[Music]
the main thing in home is for me is
cooking so i'll be cooking lots of stuff
and
you know do other work at home cleaning
and stuff and here you don't do anything
you get
lazy all day and especially if you don't
work if you work it's fine they clean
twice a week our room and they change
everything and
they clean the toilet that's why we get
lazy here yeah it's three months four
months now absolutely six months six
months yeah because we came here on 15th
of september we're comfortable
you get hot meal here it's fine
everything is okay the stuff everything
but it's not a home
it's feel like you are a guest somewhere
this is okay but it's not home it's just
room after six months with three people
living in one room some good news on 7th
of march we will move
because yeah we got three bedroom flight
yeah from arrested city council yeah
finally
and
we
accept it on straight away we haven't
said anything normally they give you a
chance to refuse it to wait for another
one but we say no we need a flat as soon
as possible we want to get out from here
[Music]
at the other hotel afzal and his family
are still waiting on news of a possible
house but a lot has changed since they
arrived at the first when we came to uk
i had three children and my wife was
pregnant afsal's heavily pregnant wife
has been due to give birth they're now
safe in britain but dealing with the
imminent arrival of a new baby far from
home and far from all their relatives is
stressful i was worried about
many things and all the times i thinking
about what's happening
next everything is
changed and no one in here
and all the times my wife was cried when
she speak with
her mom and
her
sisters in
afghanistan and
she say
what i do in here because i'm alone
my wife had
some pen in a hotel when we moved from
hotel to hospital i was being with my
wife in rome
up to
my daughter born
i took my hand my
my wife han
and the doctor was busy with
my wife
when she born the doctor put my daughter
to the
occupation unit
yeah and i went to
her and i saw my daughter
i feel very calm and i was happy
yeah she was very beautiful
i love my daughter
they're now a family of six
they were given a second room in the
hotel but after almost a year have now
moved into a home of their own sky's
lisa holland has been looking at the
number of people still in hotels
lisa what have you found out well after
the relief which you witness to it
for a lot of people comes the reality
in fact the home office have told us
that as of mid-july so almost a year on
some nine and a half thousand afghans
are still in hotels waiting for
permanent accommodation and that comes
at a cost of about a million pounds a
day now the majority of people were
evacuated on operation pitting we know
that some 4 000 people arrived after
that
but
essentially that that means 12 long
months for an awful lot of people just
becoming really quite frustrated in
those hotels i suppose the real question
here is about it's not just
the numbers of people it's a lack of
housing it does a national housing
shortage for people who you know are
british citizens already let alone
people coming from countries like
afghanistan
yeah that's really absolutely at the
heart of it
although it's a sort of complex issue
because we know things are kind of being
made worse by the fact that some of the
hotels want to sort of take their rooms
back
the bottom line is there is this
shortage of accommodation it's also more
difficult because um as far as the
afghans are concerned they've already
gone through enormous upheaval so they
don't just suddenly want to go and be
relocated to an area where they perhaps
don't feel they are going to be able to
settle in as as easily as they may have
hoped we did ask pretty patel the home
secretary to be uh interviewed on this
and she declined in a statement the home
office said the housing of afghan
individuals and families can be a
complex process and we're supporting
people with many different needs we're
working with over 300 local authorities
across the uk to meet the demand for
housing and have moved or are in the
process of moving more than 7 000 people
into homes since june 2021
so how are some local authorities trying
to source accommodation and james is the
commissioning manager for refugees at
bristol city council the government
funds the resettlement schemes it isn't
something that's funded from local
taxation it it's funded centrally from
the home office in bristol there's a
really difficult private rented market
we knew that social housing isn't an
option for refugees because we have
about 17 000 people on the waiting list
so we had to look into the private
rented sector we've all been concerned
that the desperate situation unfolding
in afghanistan and we must do all we can
to thank them for the support and the
commitment they have shown to the uk but
to do this we need landlords to offer us
properties
so we can so for our scheme we came up
with a support package for landlords so
that they would feel that the risk they
take
in
offering a tenancy to a newly arrived
resettled refugee is manageable if the
landlord
can offer us a rental property which is
of good quality at a rent which is at a
local housing allowance level which is
set by government and it's um the amount
that will be paid for rent from benefits
from universal credit
then their work as a landlord can be
minimized because we do the work so we
find the tenant we furnish the property
we clean it all up and we get it ready
it's a package which enables the
landlord to receive less money each
month
but it's an easy life the sudden full of
kabul and emergency evacuations meant
many more people were coming to bristol
than previously expected the council was
asked to help him wrap around care
bespoke support to help familiarize
refugees with their local area
everything was changing very quickly and
i went to my team to say can somebody
help me to support roundabout i think it
was 250 afghan um people who'd arrived
as family units into the two bristol
hotels we knew that the most important
thing was relationship so people needed
to feel that there was somebody in the
uk who's looking out for them like it's
okay we've got you we're going to walk
alongside you you know we're going to
support you
in in your new life
so myself and um a team of nurses
and interpreters
we sat down in the hotels and we met
each of the families and we said how are
you do you have any medical issues
do you have any needs are you pregnant
how old are the children so that we
could look at schools we spoke to the
hotel management around appropriate food
and there was also
somebody from the home office was
allocated and the home office also
organized for the local dwp the job
centre
to also come in and help with doing all
the benefit claims on a monday we would
always offer a drop in and we would
answer every question that people wanted
so for
all the refugees who are referred to us
on a resettlement scheme so they're all
referred to us through the government
then they arrive with
immigration status as the right to
health the right to education the right
to work and the right to receive welfare
benefits
so across all of the schemes
then we will support people to register
with a gp we will support people to
claim universal credit and child benefit
if relevant we will support people to
register the children into schools we
will support the adults to register into
english classes
we will show them where the local shops
are
and we show people how to use transport
we also offer people
bus passes for two months so that
they're able to get around the city
[Music]
and with a right to work some local
employers have been visiting the hotels
and job fairs to advertise opportunities
to the refugees
many are becoming restless at the hotel
and are keen to find employment
some have come from high power jobs
while others didn't have a formal
education but have practical skills
some have excellent english others don't
have any
though language classes are being
offered as part of resettlement she said
just put me in like a kitchen i have
experience in the kitchen my name is
steve cream i'm the registered care home
manager at saffron gardens working for
brunellcare we've come to a hotel today
we're working with a charity to
help get afghan refugees who are looking
to settle in bristol um into work
there's no big need for experience
we have roles in
care
i manage a care for people living with
dementia we also have support roles such
as housekeeping and kitchen assistant
laundry assistant more task-based less
english needed we can show and they can
learn by doing
there needs to be a reasonable level of
english so they can communicate with the
residents it is
after all working in their home
they've been through a lot we need to
help them establish some sense of
normality give them some worth um give
them a feeling that they're being
accepted and they're moving forward with
their lives it's something that we'd all
want in the same situation so trying to
make things as normal as possible for
people
afzal told us he was proud but also
relieved when he landed a job at the
port
they told me when you want to start job
i told them
from today
but it is good for me because every
morning i wake up about 10 o'clock or 11
o'clock and it was my habit
lazy every day by day a day be blizzy
in hotel
and all the day i was
not very good not feel very good
but jobs also let them earn an income
work with new people and learn new
skills
they import and export the new cars by
merchant ship
i am a driver i drive the car from ship
to the to the car park and from car park
to the ship and there is a lot of
difference new car and right now i
understand about all the vehicles to you
see in bristol
i can't drive
all of them if i apply for the british
license because i have afghani
international license that's very easy
for me
shibano is running a sewing class for
some of the afghan women at a community
center
she says that many of these women are
uneducated
they bring their children along to these
classes
a prayer mat in the corner allows them
to observe their religious practices
last class was for
just measurement to take measurement of
the body and now i'm trying to show them
how to put the measurement on the paper
or fabric and cut it and they will learn
it they are trying to learn it and start
their own business or something
at home yeah and also if they don't
start business they can do for
themselves they can make clothes because
it's very expensive in uk
this isn't new to shivano back in
afghanistan she also dedicated her time
to training women and girls to better
their lives i started from my own house
like
i just made a one room like on the
terrace we had a
very big room and i put machines
everything and i called just uh near to
my house the people who were poor people
and
and the girls they come
the stuff related to sewing i would buy
for them and then they come to learn it
and if some people they have much
invariable machining they couldn't use
it and i take it and fix it by the
mechanic and bring it to one lady girl
or lady to give it to them it was very
important normally in afghanistan the
woman can't do outside work like start a
shop if you go to afghanistan you will
never see a lady in the shop to selling
something i was trying to teach them my
skill and they could do their business
from home
it is not a beginner class
it is
made to measure they know how to stitch
in a little bit cutting but they are
they are saying we don't know
professionally to take the measurement
of someone
it's moving day yousef shibano their
daughter and nephew are moving into a
new three-bedroom flat a couple of miles
away from the hotel in bristol
back in afghanistan they also had an
apartment but in a block with extended
family
in afghanistan all homes
is too like buildings yeah like flats
but we we get the whole building and we
have four floors to live on first floor
i have my cousin in there the second
floor was my father's uncle
and the third floor was my
uncle's the old uncles they lived
together and the top of floor is ours
we have pigeons on our
roof yeah we keep them and they live
with us
we fly them
they go around over our home like this
carrying the stuff upstairs
their new flat in bristol is split over
two floors with a kitchen diner and
lounge all in one room two bedrooms
upstairs one downstairs and a bathroom
on each level
it's off a main road with lots of
grocery shops and other stores it's also
close to the city center
this is the toilet here
and what about this one
it's a small storage
the sitting room is a bit smaller than
we expect
it was very it was looking in the photo
very big room
yeah the photos i'm kevin i'm your
housing officer okay i'm gonna start off
just by showing you a few things around
the house just how all the appliances
work and everything
um i'll take you around the bedrooms and
just show you around and then i've got
the sign up pack i need to go through so
it's all the legal documents and
everything that we need to give you then
i'm going to need a signature from the
tenants yourself your wife
and then pretty much good to go and this
is our daughter room malala wow
one way
yeah nice coverage
i'm so happy
pink alert
so i'm donna cohen and i'm a senior
support worker with the refugee
resettlement team
i currently work with
eight afghan families so they're my
ninth from their normal background i get
a lot of feedback from them that
they never use the sofas
because they prefer to have cushions on
the floor and all sit around on the
floor i think they're used to much
bigger rooms as well
because as you know british houses tend
to have quite a lot of small rooms i
think they're used to flats as well
rather than houses
so the garden it's not something that
they desire so
it's quite helpful in bristol because a
lot of the things being built our
apartments say very good viewer we are
happy
and
it means a lot for us
there are two main resettlement schemes
for afghans coming to the uk 10 000 have
come so far under the afghan relocations
and assistance policy arab
open to people who worked for the
british government in afghanistan and
their families
six and a half thousand have been
brought to the uk under the afghan
citizens resettlement scheme the acrs
for those who are vulnerable and at risk
including women's rights activists
journalists prosecutors and members of
the lgbtq community it will be open to
up to 20 000 people over the next few
years
[Music]
but while things are moving forward for
many of the refugees who've arrived most
can't help but think of life back home
in afghanistan with an uncertain future
and those friends and loved ones who
didn't get away
afsal's wider family were against the
taliban and that is potentially very
very dangerous
he thinks they should qualify for the
acrs but he says they're still unsure
how to apply and each day is a risk for
them my brothers
my sister
my nephew my cousin all of our family
they're
stuck in afghanistan just one of my
brother he escaped
work people was a member of previous
government we fought against the taliban
afghanistan and the taliban won the war
and we lost or
if your enemy won
what's happened
two of my brothers
there wasn't a member of
a national army in afghanistan and still
there
stuck on adventists on they can't go out
anywhere he says they're in hiding and
live in fear of being called if they
arrest them they take them to somewhere
and they
we don't know
what what they do with them there are
some people previous soldiers
and previous officers if they know
surrender to the taliban
they move to uh to over overplays and
they climb up to the mountain
and still they fight against the taliban
communication is unreliable and limited
it means afsal is constantly worrying
afraid one of my brother maybe enjoying
one month i know speak yet
just two or three times i received
a sound in here
the mobile the internet that's not very
good not good quality and afghanistan
we don't know what's happening next but
i'm worried about my brothers in
afghanistan hopefully
something's happening up uh in
afghanistan some things we hope some
change that i'm gonna sound
[Music]
back in august the government conceded
that not everyone who had a right to
come to the uk was put on a flight
our community's correspondent lisa
holland is back
what have you been able to find out
about how things stand now
yep still a lot of work to do um it was
it was very vivid wasn't it back in the
day about last august
when the evacuations were taking place
and the uk's defense secretary ben
wallace spoke quite emotionally when he
acknowledged on lbc that there would not
be time to fly out all of those who were
eligible before the withdrawal deadline
it's a really deep part of regret for me
um
some people won't get back
some people won't get back and um we
will have to
do our best and third countries to
process those people information that's
been given to us uh suggests that there
are around 750
people
who are eligible confirmed have been
accepted as of early july onto the arab
scheme and it's thought that most of
them are still in afghanistan not
entirely easy to maintain communications
with everybody in afghanistan
in addition to that there are some 8 000
people who could also still be eligible
as well so these are people who
haven't yet come forward or may have
come forward and applied but haven't
been properly processed yet
in a statement the ministry of defense
said we continue to do all we can to
secure safe passage and enable british
nationals and eligible afghans to leave
the country conditions in afghanistan
can prevent easy freedom of movement for
some eligible afghans we're pursuing a
range of options to help them to reach
safety
but the situation in the country is
becoming more desperate not only from
the taliban regime but the failing
economy which means many are without
jobs money and food which may cause more
to flee to other countries
while we've been hearing about the level
of support for those on resettlement
schemes this is not the same for asylum
seekers from afghanistan who are already
in the uk awaiting a decision or who may
be arriving even now
jenny filimore professor of migration
and super diversity at the university of
birmingham says that those who come to
the uk without an approved application
stand to be treated more harshly we have
a bifurcated system in the uk and it's
evident that the government are ever
moving more towards the resettlement
model
which is
unfortunate because it absolutely does
not meet all needs
but those who arrive under a
resettlement package
money is allocated to the local
authority that takes them and then that
local authority will use that money to
um to help
identify housing
um get kids into education provide case
workers and and so on whereas afghans
who
um orbit may also have worked for the
british government or may have been in
very vulnerable positions if they arrive
spontaneously because they were unable
to be resettled
we know that the capacity for
resettlement was very low
then unfortunately those individuals
will be treated completely differently
so they will have to go through an
asylum determination process
they may end up living in a hotel or
barracks
or maybe even detained if they're
considered to be a flight risk
they'll have to demonstrate in a process
that can take many years
that they have a legitimate claim um for
being a refugee
the the difficulty for those who
are left in afghanistan is trying to
kind of weigh up do i wait do i try to
come through the official channels which
is stringently what the uk government
says they must do
or do i sort of try to chance my arm and
come by other means potentially a sort
of illegal boat crossing across the
channel um the home office has made it
very clear that that anyone arriving in
the uk
uh without being accepted on a
resettlement scheme will be treated as
an asylum seeker
asylum seekers are given a place to live
and their children um have the
opportunity to attend school they're
given an allowance of about 40 pounds a
week but they don't have the right to
work so i i think in terms of the kind
of wide picture
it's been a long year but even those who
have come on those resettlement schemes
some of those are not happy and from the
perspective of the home office it's an
enormous thing to try and and bring
people from afghanistan whereas the
mld's concerned or from the home office
to resettle people
even after this lengthy period of time
it's a very very tricky issue to solve
obviously the speed of the taliban
takeover was remarkable and the need to
get people out of the country in such a
short period of time was unexpected
however it also seems clear that there
was an underestimate on the numbers who
could qualify and of course the whole
process continues
on the next episode of out of
afghanistan we ask about integration for
the resettled refugees how easy is it to
adjust to life in britain and why is it
harder for some than others
how easy is it to make friends in a new
country
out of afghanistan was presented by me
stuart ramsey it was produced by anne
marie bullock sound designed by will
chalk and paul stanworth is the editor
you